in November you published an Oprah
letter to Hollywood yes um basically
talking about the Latino representation
or lack of and you wrote If you look
Latino or if you have a Latino last name
the odds are against you in Hollywood
kind of explain your reason for
publishing that and writing that and
where do you think we are now when it
comes to the Latino well I mean we're
the oldest ethnic group in America
where the largest ethnic group in
America we didn't just get here we've
been here for 500 years and and why are
we still invisible we're 20 of the
population and and less than one percent
of the leads in front of the camera less
than one percent of the crew behind what
less than one percent of the executives
how's that possible it's not for lack of
trying yeah you know what I mean we're
30 of the U.S box office we had 2.8
trillion dollars to the GDP we're not
getting our money's worth I want my
money's worth